I want to pick up in volume two on June the 2nd, 1899. This is about self-knowledge and
is another very important section, because the self-knowledge, as we've dealt with it
before, is one of the foundation stones. The greatest favour that can be done to a soul
is to come to know herself. This morning my most sweet Jesus wanted to let me touch my
nothingness with my own hands. Now, nothingness is one of the very important themes in this
whole thing, and we need to take a real note of this, because the only safety for us is
in our nothingness. In the act in which he made himself seen, the first word which he
addressed to me, where who am I, and who are you? This is an extremely important dialogue.
In these two words I saw two immense lights. In one I comprehended or understood God, and
in the other I saw my own misery and my own nothingness. I saw I was nothing but a shadow,
just like a shadow formed by the sun in illuminating the earth. This shadow is dependent on the
sun, and as the sun moves from it to other places, the shadows cease to exist outside
of the splendor of the sun. The same from my shadow. That is my being. It is dependent
on the mystical sun who is God, who can dissolve this shadow in one simple instant. What to
say then about how I have deformed this shadow with which the Lord Jesus gave me, which is
not even my own. The mere thought of it was horrifying. It was stinking, putrid, and full
of worms. Yet in such a horrifying state, I was forced to stand before God, who is so
holy. Hijios, otheos, and Greek, holy God. Leviticus 19, 2, you shall be holy, for I
am holy, says the Lord. O how content I would have been, Louisa said, had I been allowed
to hide in the darkness of the darkness. So we need to come to a moment with God. I had
this wonderful moment with him. Again, who am I and who are you? I am nothing. He said,
I am everything. I said, I am poverty. He said, I am plenty. I said, I am a sinner. He said,
I am your redeemer. I said, I am needy. And he said, I am your supply. I am hungry. I
am your food. Everything that we are not, he is. And that is extremely important. We have
to come to this. And if we realize that I am the I am not, then you understand that
Jesus is the one who is. Now, you get a wonderful discussion like this in John chapter 3 in
the last section of the chapter where John the Baptist said, you know, John the Baptist
was asked, are you the Messiah? He said, I am not. But Jesus was. Are you the prophet?
He said, no, I am not. Jesus was. And everything that John said he was not. Jesus was. So it
is the same with us. And to come to this realization, not in your head, but in your innermost being
is where the liberation is. After this, Jesus told me, the greatest favor I can do for his
soul is to make her know herself. Romans 7, 18. The knowledge of self and the knowledge
of God go together. If you don't know yourself, there's no possibility of getting to know
anybody else. The more you know yourself, the more you know God. When the soul has known
herself in her nothingness, she realizes that God who God is, everything that I am not,
he is. So when the soul has grown, known herself as she sees that she is nothing good by herself.
That's John 15 five, her shadow, her being transforms into God. And it happens that she
does all her operations in God and not in herself. It happens that the soul is in God
walks beside him without looking without investigating without speaking. Now that's your Genesis
338 where God walked with Adam and the cool of the day. And also proverbs 8 31 that God
wants the company of human beings. And so in a word, as if she were dead, in fact, knowing
the depth of her nothingness, she dares to do nothing by herself, but she blindly follows
the trajectory of the operations of God. So that's proverbs three verses five to eight,
my son lean not on your own understanding, lean on God. It seems to me that a soul who
knows herself is the same as those people who travel in a steamer. In moving from one
point to another without taking a step of their own, they make long journeys. But everything
is by the power of the steamer that transports them in the same way the soul by placing herself
in God, just like the people in the steamer. She makes sublime flights on the way to perfection,
knowing, however, that it's not her. But rather, she does it by the power of that blessed God
who carries her within himself. Deuteronomy 32 verses 10 and 11. He carries us like the
eagle carrying its young. Oh, how the Lord favors her and enriches her and concedes the
greatest graces, knowing that she attributes nothing to herself, but everything to him.
That's your Philippians 4 13 again. Oh soul, you who know yourself, how fortunate you are
Louisa says. So June the 3rd, 1899. Jesus pours his bitterness into Louisa. This morning
I was in a sea of affliction, but Jesus had not yet come. I felt such pain that I felt
my heart being ripped out. When the confessor came to call me to obedience for he had to
celebrate holy mass, Jesus did not let even a shadow of himself be seen as he usually
does. In fact, when he does not come, he allows his hand or his arm to be seen. That's a reminder
of his presence. And especially on a day in which I receive holy communion, as this morning
he himself comes, he purifies me and he prepares me himself to receive him in holy communion.
So try and imagine how unworthy we are if she needed all this preparation. I was saying
to myself, Holy spouse beloved Jesus, how is this? Aren't you coming to prepare me yourself?
How can I receive you? But meanwhile the time came, the confessor came and Jesus did not
come at all. What a harrowing pain and how many bitter tears. The confessor told me,
you will see him at communion and out of obedience you will ask him why he does not come and
what he wants from you. So after communion, I saw my good Jesus always kind with this
miserable sinner. He transported me outside of myself and I was holding him in my arms
for he was a child, all afflicted. Immediately I began to say my little child, my soul and
only good, how is it that you do not come? In what have I offended you? What do you want
from me that you make me cry so much? And in the act of saying this, my pain was so
great that even though I was holding him in my arms, I kept crying. But even before I
finished speaking the last word, drawing his mouth close to mine, Jesus poured his bitterness
without answering a word. When he would stop pouring, I would begin speaking again, but
Jesus would not pay attention to me and would begin to pour again. After this without answering
anything of what I wanted, he told me, let me pour into you. Otherwise, just as I have
destroyed other places with the hail, I'll destroy your place as well. Therefore, let
me pour and do not think about anything else. Now, Louisa should at this particular point
know that she should be thinking about Jesus and about her mission and not just about
herself, but we learn slowly. So, June the 5th, 1899, her miserable state, my state of
annihilation continues. It is such that I did not dare to say a word to my blessed Jesus.
But this morning, having compassion on my miserable state, Jesus himself wanted to cheer
me and hear his how. As he made himself seen, and I felt all annihilated and ashamed before
him, Jesus drew near me, but so close that it seemed that he was in me and I was in him.
Now, that's John 1420 to 21, you in me and I in you. And he said, my beloved daughter,
what is it that makes you so afflicted? Tell me everything, for I will content you and
will remedy everything. Since I continue to see myself the way I describe the other day
and seeing myself so bad I didn't dare to tell him anything, but Jesus repeated, come,
come, tell me what you want, don't hesitate. Seeing myself almost forced, bursting into
a flood of tears, I said to him, holy Jesus, how do you want me not to be afflicted after
so many graces? I shouldn't be so bad anymore. Sometimes also in the good works I try to
do. I mix so many defects and imperfections that I myself feel horror. Well, I don't know
about you, but I find that a consolation that with all the grace she receives, she still
finds it difficult not to have the human defects. And that's the same as with us all. What must
they be before you who are so perfect and holy? And then the suffering which is so very scarce
compared to before, your long delays in coming, everything tells me in clear notes that my
sins, my awful ingratitudes are the cause of it and that you, indignant with me, deny
me even the daily bread that you used to concede to everyone, which is the cross. Louisa doesn't
seem to be aware of the fact that she's telling him that she's suffering. And what is the
cross except suffering? So you will end up abandoning me completely. Can there be a greater
affliction than this? Jesus all compassion for me pressed me to his heart and he said,
do not fear. This morning we will do things together. In this way I will make up for all
this stuff. So first it seemed that Jesus had a fountain of water and another of blood
within his breast. And in those two fountains he plunged my soul. Now this is the blood
and water that came from his side after the crucifixion and they represent baptism and
the Eucharist. First the water and then the blood. Who can say how purified and embellished
my soul became? Then we began to pray together reciting three glory bees and he told me that
he was doing this to make up for my prayers and adorations to the majesty of God.
Oh how beautiful and touching it was to pray together with Jesus. After this Jesus told me,
don't let yourself be afflicted by the lack of suffering. Do you want to anticipate the hour
established by me? My work is not hurried but everything has its time. We will fulfill everything
but in the appropriate time. Now the book of Ecclesiastes chapter 3 verses 1 to 8 says,
there's a time for everything. Time for life, death, time for growth, time for deterioration,
there's a time for war, time for peace, a time for everything. Also we know that God is never in a
hurry but he's always on time. Whereas we want to rush everything. If we know something is to
happen we wanted to happen yesterday. And so because of that rush and that haste we make an
enormous number of mistakes. Then afterwards, because of a fully providential circumstance
unexpectedly, since the vieticum had come out of the church for other sick people, I too received
communion. Who can say after all that passed between Jesus and me the kisses and the caresses
that Jesus gave me. It's impossible to say everything. After communion I seemed to see the sacred host
and in the host I could see first of all the mouth of Jesus and then his eyes and then one hand
and then he showed all of himself. He transported me outside of myself and I found myself in the
vault of heavens. And then I found myself on earth in the midst of people but always together with
Jesus. Every once in a while he would repeat oh how beautiful you are my beloved. Now this is the
song of songs chapter 1 verse 15 and lots more in the song of songs where the the bridegroom
contemplates and admires his bride. He said if you knew how much I loved you and you he said how
much do you love me. On hearing these words being spoken to me I experienced such confusion that
I felt I was dying but in spite of this I had the courage to say to him Jesus my beautiful one yes
I love you very much and you if you really love me tell me also do you forgive me all the evil I
have done and but concede also suffering to me and Jesus said yes I forgive you and I want to
content you by pouring in abundance my bitterness into you and so Jesus poured his bitterness. It
seemed to me that he had a fountain of bitterness in his heart. It seemed to me that Jesus had a
fountain of bitterness in his heart received through the offenses of men and most of it he poured into
me. Now at earlier times he poured only a little into her and now he's pouring as she says herself
most of it. Then Jesus said tell me what else do you want and Louisa said Lord Jesus I commend
to you my confessor make him a saint and grant him also health for his body but then is it completely
your will for this father to come. Well she hasn't given up yet about asking to have the priest not
to come all the time and Jesus said yes it is and Louisa said if it were your will you would let him
be well and then Jesus said be quiet do not want to investigate my judgments too much
and at that very moment he showed me an improvement in the health of the body
and the sanctity of the soul of the confessor and then he added you want to rush things but I do
everything at the right time. So here Jesus is letting us know that illness when it is permitted
by God has its own function in us it has a justice function from God but it also has a mercy function
and it gives us time to recover and to repent and to change our ways and to think and to meditate
and to make good decisions so a time of illness is a time of real meditation and also it should
be a time of repentance and coming back to God. Then Louisa commended to Jesus the people who
belonged to her and she said I prayed for sinners saying to Jesus oh how I wish that my body would
split into tiny little pieces provided that sinners would convert. So I kissed the forehead the eyes
the face the mouth of Jesus doing various adorations and reparations for the offenses that sinners gave
him. Now Louisa does this at the sixth hour of the Passion and she also does it at the crucifixion
of Jesus and oh how content Jesus was and I too. Then having Jesus promise to me that he would not
leave me anymore I returned to myself and so it ended. So John 14 18 Joshua 1 5 and Hebrews 13 5.
So June the 8th 1899 Louisa wants everyone to convert. My adorable Jesus still makes himself
seen all kindness and sweetness. This morning while I was together with him he repeated again
tell me what do you want. Immediately I said Jesus my dear what I would really want is that the whole
world would convert and then in brackets she says what a request out of proportion but of course
we're told in the Acts of the Apostles that God wants all people to convert and come to the
knowledge of the truth and you also find the same thing in 1 Timothy 3. But still my loving Jesus
told me I would content you if all had the good will to be saved but not everybody wants to be saved
and yet to show you that I would gladly grant everything you have asked let us go together into
the midst of the world and all those who and all of those whom we will find with the good will to be
saved as evil as they are I'll give it to you. So poor Louisa has the terrible shock of discovering
that everybody doesn't want to be saved. So we went out into the midst of people to see who had
the good will to be saved and to our highest displeasure we found the number so very scarce
that it is sorrowful just to think about it. In this number so very scarce there was my confessor
the majority of priests and only part of the faithful nobody in the world
but not everyone from Carretto she said. Then he showed me the various offenses he was receiving.
"I prayed him to let me share in his sufferings and Jesus poured his bitterness from his mouth into
mine. After this he told me my daughter I feel my mouth too embittered. Please he said I beg you to
sweeten it." And Louisa said to him I would gladly give you anything but I have nothing that's the
John 15 5 again. "I have nothing. You yourself tell me what can I give you and he told me let me
suckle milk from your breasts. For in this way you will be able to sweeten me." Okay now this text
is a bit challenging until it is explained to you. And at the very moment he was saying this he laid
down in my arms and began to suckle as a child of course. While he was doing this a fear came upon
me that it might not be the baby Jesus but the devil and therefore I placed my hand on his forehead
and I signed him with the cross, persignium cruises. Jesus looked at me all festive and while still
suckling he smiled and with his lively eyes he seemed to tell me I'm not a demon I'm not a demon.
And after he seemed to be satiated he got up on my lap and kissed me all over.
Now since I too felt my mouth bitter from the bitterness he had poured into me I felt I wanted
to suckle from the breasts of Jesus but I didn't dare to but Jesus invited me to do it and so I
plucked up courage and began to suckle. Oh what sweetness of paradise came from that holy breast
but who can express it and then I found myself inside of myself all inundated with sweetness and
contentment okay. Now you have to know that this happened in and out of the body experience this
is nothing to do with the flesh okay and I've already told you that sucking the milk is drawing
life from the other person so Jesus was drawing life from Louisa and Louisa was drawing life from
him okay. So in the Gospel in John chapter 7 verses 37 to 39 Jesus tells us to come and drink
and if we do he says if you really believe in me come and drink and then out of your own heart
will flow fountains of living water in other words the living water represents redemption
or salvation so you'll be able to give life to others and now we have to have an explanation of
this text now I will explain that when it happens that Jesus suckles from my breast my body does
not participate in this at all this is in the realm of the spirit it happens when I am outside
of myself it seems that this thing occurs only between the soul and Jesus and when he wants to do
this he's always a child this is so true that it is only the soul and not the body that when this
happens I am always either in the vault of the heavens or wandering through other points of the
earth sometimes then I have said that as I returned to myself I felt a pain in that place from which
the baby Jesus suckled because in suckling sometimes he would do it very rather strongly
so much so that it seems that though that that suckling he wanted to pull out of my heart
pull out my heart from within my breast so notice what is being pulled out there
it's the heart and not the body and you need to understand that heart is used in these writings
to represent the the person your inner being okay so it's her heart she feels being pulled out of her
now what is it that's pulled out of your heart and it's love and as I've told you before love is the
essence of the spiritual life because God is love therefore I felt a sensible pain and as I returned
to myself the soul would communicate this pain to the body but then this happens also in other
things as for example when the Lord transports me out of myself and lets me share in his crucifixion
Jesus himself lays me on the cross and pierces my hands and feet through with nails I feel such
pain that I feel I'm dying and then when I find myself back in the body the body also participates
so much so as to be unable to move my fingers or an arm in other words what's happening is
actually real it's not just mystical as in somebody thinks this is happening in some kind of an
unreal realm and I remember that when Jesus would suckle from my breasts he would place his mouth
there but it is from my heart that I would feel him draw whatever he's suckled so much so that
while he would do this at times I have felt my heart being torn from my breast and sometimes
feeling a most vivid pain I would say to him my pretty little one indeed you are too eager you
are too hungry do it more mildly because it hurts very much and he would laugh in the same way
when it is I that suckled from Jesus it's from his heart that I draw that milk or blood so much so
that for me suckling from the breast of Jesus is the same as drinking from his side so you can see
that her problem is that she doesn't have the language to be able to explain what's actually going
on but he is drawing life from her and she is drawing life from him you and me and I in you now
that happens in every relationship but you don't talk about it graphically like this that for the
spousal relationship in marriage they both have to give life to each other otherwise the relationship
is not stable and it doesn't grow I will add also another thing Louisa said since the Lord
every now and then is pleased with pouring a most sweet milk from his mouth or with letting me drink
his most precious blood from his side then when he he wants to suckle from me he suckles nothing
else but what he himself has given this is extremely important we have nothing to give him
he actually takes from us and through us what he has already given it's a bit like a small child
picking up your favorite rose in the garden not even cutting it properly and taking it in to you
and saying mommy I love you daddy I love you the thing that is most precious is the love
but the rose was yours you're the one who bought it planted it looked after it and all the rest of
it and so Jesus is the source of all life that's john 14 6 I am the way the truth and the life
okay and so Jesus draws out of Louisa what he has already given to her because
everything comes from him he is the source of everything because she said I have nothing with
which to sweeten him but much that might embit her him this is so true that sometimes in the very
act in which he would suckle from me I would suckle from him as well and I would realize clearly
that he was drawing from me what he was drawing from from me was nothing other than what he himself
was giving to me it seems I've exclaimed myself as much as I could so what he's saying is he gives
to us to enable us to give to him so let me give you another example a little child goes up to his
daddy and he said I need more money this week and the dad says to him why do you need more money
you've got enough pocket money now the dad happens to know that his birthday is in two days time
and but the child is all mysterious and says no no this week I actually need more money
you know and so on and so eventually the father gives him extra money and with the money the
child goes out and buys a gift for the father's birthday and so on the birthday the child comes
and presents the gift now the father gave the money to the child to buy the gift but the father
couldn't buy the love and concern and the thoughtfulness of the child well that's the way it is
between God and us he has to give us what we will give to him so June the 9th 1899 it is the grave
sin of abortion I spent this morning very anguished because of the many offenses which I saw Jesus
receive from people especially because of a certain certain horrendous dishonesty that means the
deception now in the book of Revelation we're told that the four horsemen of the apocalypse
are the white horse the red horse the pale horse and the the horse of death the green one
the first one the white horse looks like the Christ but an actual fact is the antichrist
and its name is deception and one of the things that the 20th century was famous for was deception
and so the the horrendous dishonesty how much the loss of souls grieved Jesus more so since
it was a newborn baby they were going to kill without administering holy baptism to him it seemed
to me that this sin weighs so much on the scale of divine justice that is is the one that most cries
out for revenge from God don't you think the western world is in dire trouble legalizing abortion
yet these sorrowful scenes are renewed so very often she said and most sweet Jesus is so afflicted
as to arouse pity seeing him in such a state I did not dare to tell him anything and Jesus told
me my daughter unite your sufferings to mine unite your prayers to mine so that they may be more
acceptable before the majesty of God and may appear not as your things but as my own now this
is very very important that we have to fuse everything in the divine will including our prayers
because our prayers are nothing it's only when they're united to the prayers of Jesus in the divine
will that they have great power and then he continued to make himself seen other times but in silence
so june the 11th 1899
my sweet Jesus continues to make himself seen only very few times and almost always in silence
I felt my mind all confused and full of fear that I might lose my soul and only good and about many
other things which is not necessary to say here while I was in this state he made himself seen for
just a little he seemed to carry a light and from that light many other little globes of light were
coming out this is terribly important Jesus told me remove every fear from your heart see I have
brought you this globe of light now you know that God is light one John one five God is light
I brought you this globe of light to place in it between you and me and among those who approach
you for those who approach you with an upright heart and to do good to you these little globes of
light that come out will penetrate into their minds will descend into their hearts will fill
them with joy and with celestial graces and they will understand with clarity that which I am operating
in you the others then who will come with other intentions will experience the opposite and they
will be dazzled and confused by these little globes of light and louisa said I remained more
tranquil may everything be for the glory of God now you need to remember that back at the time of
Napoleon there was a famous lady called blessed Anna Maria Taige married to a very irascible man
who declared at her canonization that I can tell you this woman is a saint because
of my character and how hard I made life for her and so on and she was the mother of six children
but God gave her a globe of light and people from all over Europe from the highest
echelons in the church and state came to her looking for advice and she would look into this
globe and she would know everything that God wanted to say to them and she was able to make
people in very high places a repent she was able to tell some of them stop wasting your time
you will be in God's presence in a few weeks she was able to warn people you know to prepare for
death and to repent and all kinds of things and she got Napoleon's mother doing so much penance
for Napoleon and the damage that he was doing that his mother became a martyr of love she's not
canonized or anything so this globe of light is a very special aid that the lord gives
so June the 12th 1899 Jesus himself prepares Louisa for communion
this morning having to receive communion I was praying good Jesus to come to prepare me himself
before the confessor would come to celebrate holy mass
otherwise how can I receive you being so bad and so ill disposed she said
when I was doing this my Jesus was pleased to come and in the very act of seeing him
it seemed to me that he did nothing but dart through me with his gazes most pure
and sparkling with light mark 10 21 where he gazed at the rich young man
who can say what those penetrating gazes operated inside of me not even the shadow of
a little speck could escape that's Hebrews 1214 nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence
of God it's impossible to say it rather I would have wanted to let all of this pass in silence
because the internal operations of grace can hardly be expressed as they are with one's mouth
one Corinthians two nine rather it seems to me it would counterfeit them but lady obedience
doesn't want it and when it's for her one must close one's eyes and surrender without saying
anything else otherwise woes everywhere in fact since she is a lady by herself she makes herself
respected therefore I continue in the first gaze this is number one I prayed Jesus to purify me
so that it seemed to me that everything that shadowed my soul would be shaken off
number two in the second gaze I prayed him to illuminate me because what good comes to a precious
stone from being pure if it is not sparkling as to capture the the gaze of those who look at it
they will look at it yes but with an indifferent eye much more was I in need of that light
which would not only render my soul resplendent but would make me understand the great action I
was about to do since I was not only to be looked at but identified with my sweet Jesus
identified as your john 14 20 to 21
therefore it was not enough for me to be purged and also illuminated so in that case Jesus seemed
to penetrate through me just as the light of the sun penetrates through crystal now notice how
pure she has to be to be called crystal after this seeing that Jesus continue to look at me I said
to him most loving Jesus since you were pleased first to purge and then to illuminate me be so
kind now as to sanctify me more so since I have to receive you who are the holy of holies and
therefore it's not right that I be so different from you now you need to read one Corinthians 10
and one Corinthians 11 for Saint Paul reminding us of the holiness that we need to actually receive
Jesus in the Eucharist so always kind towards this miserable sinner at this miserable one
Jesus leaned towards me took my soul in his arms and seemed to retouch it all over with his own
hands these are called divine touches which Saint John of the cross talks about as well
beside that I want you to put Ephesians 210 we are God's work of art created in Christ Jesus
who can say what those touches of creative of his creative hands operated in me
how my passions at those touches put themselves in their place my desires my inclinations my
affections my heartbeats and my other senses sanctified by these divine touches changed into
something holy other now this is the reordering that the Lord wants to do inside of all of us
so that we can be we can come to a place where the divine will can actually not only come to us
but can reside and work in us as well so when all of these things come together united among
themselves no longer clashing as before they formed a sweet harmony for the hearing of my sweet
Jesus it seemed to me that there were like many rays of light which touched his adorable heart
oh how Jesus enjoyed himself and what happy moments those have been for me
I experienced the peace of the saints that's Philippians 4 7 the peace that passes all
understanding and guards your heart and your mind in Christ Jesus it was a paradise of
contentment and of delights for me after this Jesus seemed to clothe my soul with the garment of faith
hope and love now you know in volume one that he said I am faith I am hope and I am love therefore
she's clothed in God it's absolutely incredible and in the very act of clothing me Jesus whispered
to me the way I was to exercise myself in these three virtues in other words exercise herself in
coming ever closer to God now while I was doing this on leashing another ray of light Jesus made
me understand my nothingness now notice how often the nothingness comes in because that's our only
safe place okay I seemed to be a grain of sand in the midst of a most extensive sea which is God
and this little grain went to dissolve itself in that immense sea is it dissolved itself in God
John 14 20 to 21 then he transported me outside of myself carrying me in his arms while whispering
to me various acts of contrition for my sins now notice how often we have to say sorry
I only remember that I've been in abyss of iniquities Lord how many awful in gratitude I have towards
you now he she keeps on identifying the human race as the race that is completely ungrateful
for all that God has done so while I was doing this louisa said I looked at Jesus he had the crown
of thorns on his head so I stretched out my hand and I removed it from him saying give me give the
thorns to me beloved Jesus for I am a sinner the thorns be fit me and not you who are the just one
the holy one so Jesus himself drove the crown of thorns onto my head then I don't know how I saw
the confessor from afar immediately I prayed Jesus that he would go to prepare the confessor
to be able to receive him in holy communion and Jesus seemed to go to him after a little he came
back and said to me I want the way you deal with me and with the confessor to be one
and I want the same from him he must look at you and deal with you as if you were another me
another words were to see Christ in each other and were to deal with Christ in each other
because since you are a victim soul as I was I want no difference at all
and this so that everything may be purged and my love and my love alone may shine in everything
that's John 15 9 Louisa said to him Lord this seems impossible that I may deal with the confessor
as one deals with you especially in seeing the instability that is in him and Jesus said yet
let it be so true virtue true love makes everything disappear destroys everything and with enchanting
mastery makes God alone shine through all its operations and it looks at everything in God
so that's what he's looking for after this the confessor came to call me to obedience and then
celebrate holy mass and so it ended and then I listened to holy mass and I received holy communion
now who can say the intimacy that passed between Jesus and me it's impossible to manifest it
I have no words to make myself understood so I will leave it there now in the higher volumes
she won't be allowed to just leave things like that she will be expected to actually describe it
but I want to give you one Corinthians two nine there so June the 14th 1899 Jesus wants to chastise
the world this morning most loving Jesus wouldn't come in my interior I kept thinking how is it he's
not coming what's new now yesterday he came so often and today the hour is getting late and
he's not yet showed himself at all what heartbreak what patience it takes with Jesus I absolutely
love that expression we say that of each other but I mean she's saying it about the Lord it seemed
to me that my whole interior was taking up arms for it wanted Jesus and it waged such a war against
me as to give me the pains of death my will superior to everything tried to put peace by persuading
the senses inclinations desires and affections and all the rest are calmed down for for Jesus
would come so after prolonged suffering Jesus did come carrying a cop in his hand full of coagulated
blood putrified and stinking and he told me do you see this cup of blood I will pour it over the world
that meant of course horrendous chastissments because I need to just remind you again sin rises
up from the earth nothing unholy or unworthy can enter the presence of God so the sin is sent back
to the earth as chastissments to put a kind of a little smile on it I always say there's a post
office up in heaven that says return to sender this can't arrive here so while Jesus was saying
this blessed mother came and most the the most holy virgin and my confession came with her
they prayed to Jesus that he would not pour it over the world but have me drink it
the confessor said to him lord why keep her as a victim soul if you don't want to pour it over
her I absolutely want you to let her suffer to spare the people blessed mother was crying
and insisted with Jesus and with the confessor that he would not give up praying until Jesus
would be content in accepting the exchange Jesus insisted that he wanted to pour it over the whole
world and at first he almost seemed to frown I saw myself all confused I was unable to say
anything because the sight of that cup full of blood so ugly was so horrifying as to cause my
whole nature to tremble what would it be like to drink it however I was resigned if the lord would
give it to me I would accept it who can say then the chastisement contained in that blood
if the lord would pour it over the world it seems that from this very day he keeps the hail prepared
now hail was always considered one of the great chastisements from god but not the tiny hail that
you get in Ireland in other countries the hail is so large that it can destroy cars and kill people
and do terrible destruction and so he keeps the hail prepared which will cause great damage
and it seems that it must continue in the following days but then Jesus seemed a little bit more
cam so much so that he seemed to embrace the confessor because he had prayed him in that way
however without coming to any conclusion or whether he would pour it over the people or not
and so it ended leaving me an indescribable pain because of what may happen
so june the 16th 1899 as talking about the chastisements to humiliate humanity
Jesus still continues to make himself seen with the intention to chastise. Louisa prayed him to
pour his bitterness into her and to spare the whole world and if this were not possible to spare at
least those who belonged to her and her own town. You need to remember Genesis 18 where Abraham
prayed for Sodom and Gomara and he started with 50 people and then realizing that the town was
really bad he said 45 40 and he went down to five just there wasn't even one lot and his family were
not even decent people. The intention of the confessor also seemed to unite with this intention
Louisa said so it seemed that conquered by the prayers Jesus poured a little bit from his mouth
but not from that cup mentioned above. That little bit that he poured he seemed to pour in order to
somehow spare my town of Corrato though not completely as well as those who belong to me.
However this morning I myself have been the cause of affliction to Jesus
since after he had poured I saw him more calm without thinking I said to him my beloved Jesus
I pray you to free me from the bother I caused the confessor oh dear she's back to that again
she just doesn't let go. So you have to free me from the bother I caused the confessor of having
him come every day. Now the reason why the priest has to come every day Louisa doesn't understand
at all and it is this that Jesus is about to make a most incredible revelation to the world about
the opening of the kingdom of the divine will. He's going to use Louisa as the key to opening
and therefore he has to force the church to be involved because the church is able to
neglect these victim souls and say yeah another victim soul you know and and pay no attention to
them whereas Jesus was actually forcing the church to get involved and so it wasn't wonderful when
Louisa kept on asking that he wouldn't come. What would it cost you to free me yourself releasing
me from the state of sufferings yourself just as you yourself put me in it. Indeed it would cost
you nothing and if you want you can do everything but while I was saying this Jesus face turns so
afflicted that I felt that affliction penetrate deep into my innermost heart and without telling
me a word he disappeared. How mortified I remained the Lord alone knows thinking especially that he
might not come anymore. However after a little he did come back but would greater affliction
with his face all swollen and full of blood from offenses he had just received.
All sad he said look at what they've done to me how can you say that you don't want me to chastise
creatures. Justicements are necessary in order to humiliate them and not let them grow even worse
so I need to give you Isaiah chapter 2 verses 9 11 17 and 22 and in those verses Isaiah says
that the pride of man must be brought low the pride of man must be brought low the pride of man must
be brought low and the reason is that pride is the opposition to God it's the gracious sin
it's the wall that we build between ourselves and God to keep him out and unless that wall is
brought down the human race will never see its nothingness it will never grow in self-knowledge
and therefore it will never be able to repent and come back to God so unfortunately the chastisments
are really necessary. So June the 17th 1899 Louisa doesn't want to take part in the chastisments
it continues always in the same way but this morning especially I have done nothing but
argue with my dear Jesus you can see this is a real relationship. He wanted to keep sending the
hail as he did in these past days but I didn't want it but then in the middle of all this it
seemed that a thunderstorm was getting ready commanding the demons to destroy several places
with the scourge of the hail. Now I don't know whether her thunderstorm is our hurricane or not
something very damaging and at that very moment I saw the confessor calling me from afar
giving me the obedience to go and put the demons to flight so that they might not do anything.
As I went to go there Jesus came to me making me draw back I said to him blessed Lord I can't
it is obedience that called me and you know that you and I must surrender to this virtue
without being able to oppose it. Jesus said very well I'll do it for you and so he commanded the
demons to go to places far away and not to touch for now the lands belonging to our town. Notice
that for now because don't forget the Lord knows human beings and you might be good for a day or
a week or a month and then go back to your old ways. Then he said to me let us go so we came back
eye to my bed and Jesus beside me. As we arrived Jesus wanted to rest saying that he was very tired
I stopped him saying to him what is this sleep that you want to have now and then a beautiful
obedience you had me do you want you want to sleep is this the love you have for me and the way you
want to content me and everything do you want to sleep sleep then as long as you give me your word
that you won't do anything. Oh dear my reaction to that is who's being impertinent one of the things
that human beings probably will never learn is that we should not tell God what to do. He's the
one who knows what to do we're the ones who don't know what to do but we think we do because we think
we're little gods. So being sorry for my discontent Jesus told me my daughter yet I would like to
content you and let us do it this way. Let us go out together again in the midst of people
and let us see who are those who need to be punished because of their wicked actions.
Who knows whether at least under the scourge they might surrender and that's of course the whole
point of chastisement that they might change their minds and surrender and open up to God
and then those whom you want those who need less to be punished and whom you don't want to be
punished I will spare. So Louisa said Lord I give you thanks for your highest goodness in wanting
to content me but in spite of this I cannot do what you're telling me. I do not feel the strength
to put my will into chastising any of your children. What would be the torment of my poor heart in
hearing that that person or that other has been chastised and I've put my will into it?
May it never be may it never be oh Lord and then the confessor came to call me to myself and
so it all ended. So this clash of wills I want to give you Isaiah 55 verses 4 to 8.
Now Louisa is going to have to go through an immense transformation and her confusion is really
really understandable. She's called to be a victim soul and that is that she's to do the
punishment to prevent the chastisements but as things get worse and worse and worse in the 20th
century the Lord will only allow her to mitigate the chastisement by one third which is huge when
you consider it's one person and when he brings her fully into his divine will and to operating
in the divine will she has to agree to everything that the divine will wants and in the end she has
to agree but her vocation has changed at that point she has stopped being a victim soul and she's
now the person who's the key to opening the kingdom of God the kingdom of the divine will to the rest
of us. So there's going to be an enormous transformation in Louisa. She herself doesn't know yet.
So during the 19th 1899 instability in doing good. Yesterday having gone through a day of
purgatory because of the almost total privation of my highest good and because of the many temptations
that the devil put into me it seemed that I had committed a lot of sins. Now we're all likely
Louisa we think that because you've been tempted that you've committed the sin but if you go to
confession and you say to the priest I think I may have given in or I may not then you've no matter
for confession. It's only a matter for confession if you did give in. Oh God she said what pain to
offend him. This morning as soon as I saw Jesus immediately I said to him good Jesus forgive me for
my many sins I committed yesterday and I wanted to tell you all the evil I felt I had done but
interrupting me he said if you make yourself disappear you will never commit sins. What is he
saying? Nothingness get into your nothingness and that's how you actually deal with things.
So make sure you write nothingness there on your page get into your nothing as he said and you won't
get into trouble. So forget yourself that's the VIP message in these early volumes and if you
don't forget yourself then you're not going to be able to do what God wants. If you make yourself
disappearing said you'll never commit sins. I wanted to continue to speak but Jesus making me see many
devout souls and showing he did not want to hear what I wanted to tell him. In other words he was
talking about her little bits itsy bitsies and he wanted to talk out to her about the great things
that were happening in the earth. So he needs her to think and to see the way he thinks and sees.
So he showed many devout souls and showing he did not want to hear what I wanted to tell him he
began to speak. That which most displeases me about these souls he said is their instability
in doing good and we've had this subject before a few pages back. One little thing one disappointment
even one defect is enough and while this is the time in which it is more necessary for them to
cling more to me they become irritated they become disturbed and they neglect the good which they
have started. So here you have the instability everything's fine while you feel good but if
there's any kind of a challenge and you're not feeling wonderful then you don't persevere.
How many times I have prepared graces to give to them he said but in seeing them so unstable I've
been forced to hold them back. Then knowing that he didn't want to hear anything of what I wanted
to tell him now notice how tenacious she is in holding on to her own opinion. She wants to tell
him something and that's that. So he can tell her all the things he likes but she wants to come back
to this point that's just the way we are we stick tenaciously to our own opinion. We've got to let
that go she will as well. Then knowing yeah I prayed at length for him sorry and seeing that
my confessor was not well she said I prayed at length for him and I asked Jesus many questions
was not necessary to say here. So I want to finish this section with a lovely piece from
June the 20th 1899 the love with which St. Aloysius operated. St. Aloysius was a 19 year old Jesuit
student who lived in Rome who took out his PhD in loving. It continues always the same way this
morning it seems that Jesus wanted to cheer me a little bit after I had gone in search of him for
some time. I saw a child from afar like lightning that falls down from heaven. I ran up to him and
as I arrived I took him in my arms. A doubt came to me that it might not be Jesus and I said to him
my dear little treasure tell me who are you? He said I am your dear and beloved Jesus.
And I said to him my beautiful little baby I pray you to take my heart and bring it with you to
paradise for after the heart the soul will come again two Corinthians five one to ten.
And Jesus seemed to take my heart and he united it so much with his own that they became one.
Afterwards heaven opened because that's where Jesus's heart lives. It seems that a very great
feast was being prepared. At that very moment a young man of lovely appearance came down from
heaven all dazzling with fire and flames that's love. Because fire and flames are the image of love.
Jesus told me tomorrow is the feast of my dear Aloysius I must go and attend.
Louisa said and so you leave me alone what shall I do and he said you you can come.
Look how beautiful Aloysius is but the gracious thing in him which distinguished him on earth was
the love with which he worked. Now here we're getting the emphasis on love all the time and
the centrality of love. Everything was love in him love occupied him interiorly love surrounded
him externally so one can say that even his breath was love. This is why it is said of him
that he never suffered a distraction isn't that incredible? Because love inundated him everywhere
and with this love he will be inundated eternally as you see. And in fact it seemed that the love
of Saint Aloysius was so very great as to be able to burn the whole world to ashes.
That's the love stronger than death that you see at the end of the Song of Songs.
Then Jesus added I stroll over their highest mountains and there I form my delight and don't
forget the highest mountains are the saints. Since Louisa didn't understand the meaning of it
Jesus explained the highest mountains are the saints who have loved me the most and in them I
form my delight both when they are on earth and when they pass into heaven so everything is love.
Matthew 25 verses 18 to 31. Deuteronomy 6 verses 4 to 10. 1 John 4 7. 1 Corinthians 13 13 and 1
Corinthians 14 1 and of course Ephesians 3 and 16 to 21. That will give you a bit on love.
There's a lot more as well. So I'm going to leave it there just for now and we will continue
but it was very nice to finish with the whole central theme which is love.